- It's just mental.
Tomorrow, go and do something
you've been wanting to do,
This is not Airport Gary.
Well like, I'm not gonna put this on.
That you're desperately scared about
what your parents, the world, the market,
you social media followers will think.
Do it and then see how not scary
all the negativity actually is.
("Belly" by "Slice" Wong)
There aren't right answers.
Tomorrow, do the thing that
you've been scared to do
that is the most practical,
not move across the country,
something practical.
Start a YouTube page,
tweet about something.
Like something, something.
You have to understand
there's just decisions,
there's no right or wrong,
let me tell you why.
When you make a decision, you don't know
what happened of the other decision.
Do one thing that makes you uncomfortable,
see the reaction from the audience
and your inner family and your friends
and realize very quickly
that it wasn't as scary
as you thought, that feedback.
To go from here to here
because I'm not even
asking you to go to here,
you've gotta understand,
there's no right answers.
There's just doing.
What?
- [Drock] So it's been a minute.
- It has.
I have an idea.
Something just caught my attention.
In the meme video, can you have somebody
design one that starts the,
the top left is a two times bigger version
of my Instagram logo?
- [Drock] Okay.
- I think it might stop people even more.
The calm before the storm.
Yeah, speaking in New Orleans
to a pretty awesome crew
of contractors, insurance
policy executives and
so, just ready to rock.
- [Announcer] Everybody stand
up and give a big welcome
for Gary Vee!
(audience applause)
- How are you?
- [Man] Dude great to see you again man.
- It's always good to see you bro.
- [Man] First of all thank you so much
for everything you put out.
I've been following, watching
what you've been doing
for years and have built my brand off of
my version of that.
- I love it.
Let's stay in the theme of
Crush It and Crushing It.
Let's go into it a little
deeper because maybe,
maybe you'll inspire more than I will.
How did that first start?
Like gimme the details behind that.
When did you first find me, when was that
and where were you at
and what happened next?
- [Man] Started following
you when you wrote Crush It
and became kind of just a follower,
just watched kind of self
indicative at that point.
I was working in the corporate world.
- Okay.
- I didn't have my own agency,
I didn't have my own company
and certainly didn't have my new company.
But watched what you did
and saw how you did it
very thoughtfully and
very real and very humbly
which I thought was the key to this.
So just fast forward, I've
been following you for years.
March 6, 2017, in a Facebook
group, CPA Accounting person,
in a Facebook group, somebody needed help
writing Ad Copy, you know the story.
I went into the group and
helped them rewrite their ad
in the group which led
to 15 people saying,
wow I wish I could write ads like that.
And then I made the
stupid mistake of saying,
if you ever need help, email me or DM me.
That week I had 100 requests
and my company soared.
Six months later we hit the local scale
and you at dinner in October recommended
that I get an operations person.
Best fucking advice ever.
- I'm good at this shit.
(audience laughing)
- [Man] No dude I sent you
email with the snapshot.
You saw that email?
- I did.
- [Man] Our revenue
stream, like that since
I brought a brand.
- Guys, self-awareness.
You don't have to be great at everything.
You have to be great at figuring out
what you're great at and
then surrounding yourself
with everything else.
Humility.
You've got your ego caught
up in this narrative.
Excuse me for a second while
I've got you guys, hiring.
So many of you have not fired somebody
that you desperately need to fire
because you're the one that hired them
and you have more pride
in being good at hiring
than running a good business.
This is the psychology that matters.
- [Man] So my question to you is this.
In my breakout presentation,
I'm actually showing people
how to build that brink,
everything you talk about.
Just my version of it.
How do I get our customers, our clients
to stop giving a fuck about
the buy now, click here,
get into my funnel and
get into the storytelling
of their business?
- You don't.
What you do is what I do which is
you're gonna go on a journey of spending
a fucking decade
exhaustively standing up here
yelling and screaming and ranting
or calmly or whatever you do.
All you can do is put out the
truth and let the chips fall.
You heard me very carefully.
Two.
My great ambition here is
that two of you listen and do.
That is some bullshit numbers.
There's hundreds and
hundreds of people here
but that's what I've learned
which is like, you can't.
What you can do is aspire
humbly and authentically
to get them there and
then just let your skill
and talent and work
ethic create the legacy
of how many people you
were able to get there.
Right, look how I'm thinking about it.
From my tree, it's like a coaching tree.
From my tree to you, to
you to them and so for me,
there's enormous amount of
pride in how many people
I've been able to hit but some of them
maybe in your breakout session.
I'm here and you're here.
Some of the people here
didn't get hit by what I said
but maybe in your breakout session do
and honestly that feels incredible for me
because I know where that seed started.
(audience applause)
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Thanks New Orleans.
- Did you see mom signing the book?
- No.
- Mom got asked to sign a book.
- It's gonna start soon.
Mom better start working on her signature.
Negativity can be leading at halftime.
But positivity always wins championships.
- Are you taking on new shoes?
- What's that?
- Bringing out new shoes?
A new set, like a new style or anything?
Oh, okay perfect.
- Three and four.
- You've just changed me.
- Thank you brother.
- I'll be one of your two.
- Thank you brother, makes sense right?
- Yeah well, I'm a writer,
I'm an ex-director,
I'm an ex-movie producer,
and I'm not doing anything with video.
- That's fuckin' crazy.
Like the fact that you have that
and you probably like it.
- I love it.
- Yeah, to me that is like super ignorant.
- You have any rule or ritual,
anything that you do with your life?
- I've one rule.
Try to give more to the other person
than I want in return.
- Right.
- Every interaction.
- What about everyday before coffee?
Anything, nothing weird?
- Not for me.
- Nothing.
- But man, I'm doing it
every second of my life.
I'm trying to give you a better answer
than giving you an answer
that has value for me.
- Right, right.
Give 'em more back than you got.
- 51, 49.
- Appreciate it.
- Biggest changes in like, content like,
do you think it's--
- Audio.
Audio.
There's no straight.
There's three things.
But there's moments where there's spikes
and when there's spikes,
it's like real estate.
There's land grab.
There's a land grab in
podcasting right now.
- Still sold on podcast?
- 100%
- Alright.
- We're on Facebook,
Instagram, about to get on,
I'm trying to push us to get onto YouTube.
LinkedIn is like in the
works and so is Twitter.
- But it's also not just
wide, which I believe,
but it's deep.
- Yeah.
- Like you could be on Facebook,
you could be a contractor, you
could be a real estate agent,
you could be a basketball player
but are you winning?
You gotta make sure
you get your depth down
along with your width.
Too many people think
like oh we're gonna add
podcasting, we're gonna add this.
But like the thing that
I think I'm doing well
is it's wide and deep.
But that's why there's 17 fuckin' people.
And I'm not even happy.
I think people don't realize
to be great, you need both.
You need to be wide and deep.
You just saw the highlight.
That's why Drock is pushing me to expand.
A lot of you think the answer is,
well I'll start a podcast this year
or I'll start a blog too,
or I'll do YouTube videos
too with my Facebook
or vice versa.
A lot of you are like oh,
now I'm gonna do Facebook,
Facebook Watch along with my YouTube.
The problem is 99% of you haven't gotten
the thing you're doing down, right?
So it's, that's the key to me.
I think a lot of people are confused by
what's working for me.
You know, I'm not always just obsessed
with doing everything,
I'm obsessed with doing
everything right and deep
and getting the value out of it
but also not being crippled.
For example, we had Facebook
down a year and a half ago.
I don't feel like we have it down.
I think we've mailed it in
a little bit in a podcast
kind of Instagram world back on my team
so now I'm like oh shit, over
here I've gotta go deeper.
So it's not only about going
wide or deep in a moment,
it's about going wide
and deep at all times
and understanding you're
pulling those levers.
So you're just always
getting your game better.
It's like being a
professional athlete like
you know, even the best,
the LeBrons, the Stephs,
the Kobes, they talk about
like refining their game
in season 12 of a hall of fame career.
I'm in a hall of fame career.
I'm trying to get better at every nuance,
deeper, wider, always and too many of you
are confused at just adding something,
widening out is the solve, is the unlock.
There's no fuckin' solve or unlock,
there's just a fuckin' process.
- Thank you.
- That last clip with that kid,
that's gonna really help a lot of people.
That's a real clip.
Worry about your craft, not the algorithm.
It is, that's the meme.
Now I'm so happy for you.
Not for anybody else back
home so that makes me happy.
No time to post, there's no hashtag,
there's no certain content,
there's no certain people
that follow you, there is no hack.
What there is is consistency,
of like putting out great content.
- I think the thing that
people are missing about
the working 20 hour a day train is
it's not about that, you
have consistently said.
You just have to be
disciplined not to give up.
I mean, yes work hard but the point is
don't work hard and then quit.
Like work hard for a decade.
Be self-aware
because self-awareness and
perseverance and delusion,
you know perseverance
and delusion, look Ryan,
you're gonna be successful in pretty much
anything you do because you
have the tools to be successful,
you understand the patterns that like,
you'll be successful.
If you texted me tomorrow
and be like dude,
sold the house, the tree house,
starting a lemonade
business direct to consumer
and Amazon, I'm like that's
gonna be a successful
lemonade business.
But that's the same way that like,
you know LeBron would be successful
if he wanted to be a football player.
Now he might not be NFL but he's just
a fucking beast athlete.
I think there's a lot of people right now
that want to be an entrepreneur
because it's a like
a rockstar status stuff
right now but they can't.
And so for me, self-awareness like
I don't want people to just not give up
because guess what,
there's a lot of people
that have been trying to
build a business for 11 years
and it's never gonna happen but
they could be an amazing number three.
They should be you and I number three.
So self-awareness, delusion,
complaining's my biggest one.
Literally 98% of my
conversation is predicated on
if you're unhappy, the
strategy that does not work is
going to other people's
social media and trolling them
because you're unhappy with yourself
or going to the bar at 4:30
and drinking three Bud Lights
and complaining to the bartender,
that's not the strategy.
Tomorrow, go and do something
you've been wanting to do
that you're desperately scared
about what your parents,
the world, the market,
you social media followers will think.
Do it and then see how not scary
all the negativity actually is.
You have to understand,
there's just decisions,
there's no right or wrong
because let me tell you why.
When you make a decision, you don't know
what happened of the other decision.
Do one thing that makes you uncomfortable,
see the reaction from the
audience and your inner family
and your friends and realize very quickly
that it was as scary as you thought.
That feedback.
("Unburnable" by Miteh)